on
va commencer donc ce soir
sur ce thème que je vais évoquer de la
tour de babel à l'échelle de jacob
on va lire quelques versets dans le
chapitre 11
du livre de la genèse
et
nous disons donc
ce qui concerne
la tour
or toute la terre parler un même langage
avec les mêmes mots
parti de lorient ils trouvèrent une
ville au pays de chine et a really
habitèrent il se donne à l'autre allant
faisons des briques et cuzon les au feu
avec le service de pierre et le bitume
leur servit de mortier il dit encore
allons bâtissions nous une ville et une
toux dont le sommet touche aussi allez
faisons nous un nom afin que nous ne
soyons pas dispersés sur toute la
surface de la terre
de tes rêves des 110 pour voir la ville
et la tour que baptisés les fils des
hommes et terrell dit voici un seul
peuple une par là même langage et voilà
ce qu'ils ont entrepris de faire
maintenant il n'y a plus d'obstacle à ce
qu'ils ont décidé de faire allons
descendants et la confondant leur
langage afin qu'ils n'entendent plus le
langage des uns des autres déterrer les
disséminer loin de là sur toute la
surface de la terre ils cessèrent de
bâtir la ville c'est pourquoi on appela
du nom de babel car c'est là que
l'éternel confondit le langage de toute
la terre et c'est de là que l'éternel et
disséminés sur toute la surface de la
terre
ces épisodes de la tour de babel a donné
lieu à deux très nombreux commentaires
et notamment sur le fait de savoir
quel était le péché des gens de babel
pour laquelle ils ont été châtiés par le
seigneur
l'a l'opinion la plus courante c'est que
il avait élevé une tour haute
qui a indisposé le seigneur
et que à cause de cela et bien le
seigneur est intervenue
mais cette tour qu'ils avaient
construite et est une misérable
taupinière en face de ce que le seigneur
dans sa grandeur peut connaître
et est ce que on peut se demander
vraiment si dieu et contre les bâtiments
élevés contre l'impasse state building
c'est peu probable
une volonté chercher ailleurs
la deuxième opinion
c'est que le seigneur voulait qu'ils se
dispersent sur toute la surface de la
terre et qu'ils ont voulu rester
ensemble
ça aussi c'est une opinion qui ne tient
pas la route
parce que dans la bible rassemblement
est toujours positif
et la dispersion au contraire est
toujours négative la dispersion c'est
l'exil c'est le châtiment c'est le juge
c'est le jugement
par conséquent là aussi c'est une
opinion qui n'est pas valable
quel est donc le péché des jaunes va bel
et bien cela nous est dit dans le texte
que nous avons eues
faisons-nous un an
se faire un nom
et là il faut souligner l'importance du
nom dans la bible le nom ça n'est pas ce
mort comme dans notre culture une
mention sur un registre d'état civil
le nom c'est la personne même
et nommer quelqu'un ou nommé quelque
chose c'est prendre autorités sur ce
quelqu'un ou sur ce quelque chose
par exemple
conduit au commencement créé
dans le récit du premier chapitre de la
genèse
dieu nomme
ce qu'il a créé
et par exemple la lumière il appelle
jour
et les ténèbres il appelle nuit
plus ensuite
lama désolé à bilal l'appel mer et le
sait qu il appelle terre
quand dieu nomme ainsi les objets qu'il
a créé ça veut dire
il reconnaît que
c'est sa création
et par conséquent qu'il a autorité sur
ces choses
il va donner cette même mission à
l'homme
et le premier commandement qui est
donnée
à adam et eve n'est pas comme on le
pense généralement de ne pas manger de
l'awb de la connaissance du bien et du
mal mais c'est soyez féconds multipliez
remplissez la terre est dominée sur elle
et dans le deuxième chapitre de la
genèse alors dominé sur elle le texte
ajoute suez dominé sur les oiseaux du
ciel sur les poissons de la mer et sur
les bêtes des champs
effectivement au deuxième chapitre ou
nuit la genèse nous voyons dieu qui fait
venir tous les animaux vers l'homme pour
que nomme l'homme les nomme
et en nommant les animaux
l'homme
prenez autorité sur est sur eux et
remplissent et par conséquent la mission
que le seigneur lui avait confié de
données de dominer sur la clé créatures
de dieu
nous avons cela aussi dans un texte
magnifique que le 83e chapitre du livre
du prophète isaïe où il dit ceci ainsi
parle le seigneur le seigneur qui t'a
créé jacob celui qui t'a forme et israël
ne crains pas je suis avec toi je
t'appelle par ton nom
je t'appelle partout non parce que je
t'ai créé
là aussi les relations entre le fait
d'être une créature de dieu
et le fait que du jeune homme je
t'appelle par ton nom et parce que je
t'appelle par ton nom tu es à moi j'ai
autorité sur toi mais non seulement j'ai
autorité sur toi mais en même temps j'ai
des responsabilités envers toi c'est
pourquoi tu n'as rien à craindre
et
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
ce sont les parents qui nomme l'enfant
qui vient de naître
et nous retrouvons cela notre culture
moderne
là aussi c'est encore le rôle des
parents de nommer l'enfant et en nommant
l'enfant qu'est ce que les parents font
et disent nous reconnaissons que cet
enfant et notre enfant c'est nous c'est
nous qui lui avons donné le jour et par
conséquent nous avons autorité sur lui
et nous avons des responsabilités à son
endroit c'est ce que nous affirmons en
le nommant
et voilà ici les hommes de babel
eux
refusent d'être nommé par dieu
faisons-nous un an
ça veut dire ils refusent l'autorité il
refusa souveraineté de dieu sur eux
ils refusent l'autorité de dieu sur leur
ville sur le retour sur leur
civilisation
et là est bel et bien le péché du champ
de babel
faisons-nous un nom c'est à dire
révoltons-nous contre dieu
et babel c'est la ville de la révolte
c'est la ville d'où lui est exclu et par
conséquent
dieu va intervenir contre cette ville
pour
exercer un jugement qui se prend à la
forme d'un exil
et qui va provoquer le fait que la ville
sera d'être construite
avec évidemment toujours cette nostalgie
qui n'a cessé de hanter la mémoire de
l'humanité depuis les origines
achevé reconstruire et achever babel
il faudra attendre le livre de
l'apocalypse pour que nous trouvions
babylone babel babylone c'est la même
chose n'est-ce pas cette fois ci
totalement achevée
et ce péché des gens de babel de se
faire un nom
et directement en opposition avec le
chapitre xii du livre de la genèse
en général
on fait une séparation importante entre
le chapitre 11 et le chapitre xii de la
genèse
on considère que les onze premiers
chapitres du agenaise concerne
l'histoire de l'humanité dans son
ensemble et que à partir du chapitre xii
c'est l'histoire d'abraham et cette
histoire du peuple d'israël qui commence
et il vient souvent un sous titre qui
sépare ces deux chapitres 11 et 12
en réalité il faut faire abstraction des
sous titres geoffrey abstraction de la
numérotation des chapitres est déversée
et réalisé qu'en fait du chapitre 11 et
le chapitre xii livre de la genèse
forment une seule et même unité
littéraire
et nous trouvons abraham
abraham qui va sortir de babel
qui est si j'ose dire lui aussi pris
dans ce mouvement
d'exil
qui part de cet endroit qui signifie un
acadien babylone babylone c'est la forme
grec de du mois cadiens bab in line ce
qui signifie la porte des dieux
mais voilà abraham qui va quitter cet
endroit
est le seigneur lui dis ceci
va t'en de ton pays de ta patrie de la
maison de ton père vers le pays que je
te montrerai je ferai de toi une grande
nation je bénirai je rendrai ton nom
grand
et là nous retrouvons le nom
ce nom
que les gens de babel
n'avait pas voulu recevoir de dieu
il avait voulu se nommer eux mêmes
et pour reprendre le vieux slogan des
anarchistes
c'était ni dieu ni maître
être leur propre maître ne devoir être
responsable à personne si ce n'est à eux
seuls
et alors que dieu disperse ses jours sur
toute la surface de la terre
dieu va prendre parmi ces exilés un
homme abraham
qui lui va accepter de se laisser nommer
par dieu
et c'est en cela que abraham va être le
prototype d'une humanité nouvelle
une humanité qui contrairement à
l'humanité issus de babel qui ne veut
dépendre de personne et surtout pas de
dieu
abraham lui au contraire accepte d'obéir
à dieu ça veut dire il accepte la
souveraineté de dieu ils acceptent
d'être nommé par dieu et dieu lui fait
cette promesse je rendrai ton nom cran
remarquons qu'il ya une promesse un peu
identique les fêtes à david beaucoup
plus tard
et dieu dira à david gérant du ton nom
grands aussi grand que tous les grands
de la terre
et si david est un homme selon le coeur
de dieu
un homme qui est le chantre agréable à
l'éternel comme le dira un autre texte
c'est précisément parce que lui aussi il
accepte la souveraineté de dieu sur sa
vue il accepte d'être nommé par dieu
et abraham pas sorti
de cette ville orgueilleuse qu'est
babylone
vine qui se considère comme la porte des
dieux autrement dit comme la porte du
ciel
cette ville qui se veut la métropole
religieuse de toute l'humanité et qui
d'une certaine manière le restera
pendant toute l'antiquité au moins
jusqu'à la période alexandre le grand
et à ce titre la babylone c'est la porte
du ciel
c'est
comme le disait hier le rabbin c'est le
point de rencontre entre le ciel et la
terre entre le le monde fini et puis le
monde infini entre le temps et entre
l'éternité
et pendant toute l'antiquité
les hommes et les femmes de quelques
peuples qu'ils appartiennent viendront à
babylone pour chercher
cette expérience mystique en quelque
sorte
et voilà que abraham est invité à
quitter cette métropole religieuses du
monde ancien
et dieu lui dit va vers le pays que je
te montrerai
un pays qui ne nomme pas du moins dans
un premier temps
et qui sera le pays de la bénédiction
il est très intéressant de remarquer que
jodie abraham qui ne pourra pas voir la
promesse qui lui fait d'être bénie et
d'être en bénédiction
s'il demeure en babylon et
u17 en babylonie la ville dure elle est
à quelque distance de babylone dont on
peut dire que c'est de babylone que
sobre
va vers le pays que je te montrerai
et c'est dans ce pays là que je te
donnerai cette bénédiction et que tu
pourras devenir toi aussi tu toi aussi
une bénédiction pour toutes les nations
de la terre selon la volonté de dieu en
ce qui le concerne et
et c est ainsi qu abraham pas venir
s'établir dans la terre promise
puis ce sera isaac on était dans le
tombeau des patriarches aujourd'hui et
nous avons vu ces trois générations
abraham isaac et jacob
et c'est ainsi que nous arrivons à la
troisième génération la génération de
jacob
et la génération de jacob est une
génération très spécial
il vient en effet
un conflit entre les deux frères jumeaux
et zaü et jacob
un conflit dans lequel jacob ne va pas
jouer leur rôle
bien que en fin de compte il soit celui
par lequel va passer la promesses qui
avaient été faites à bram d'être bénie
et d'être en bénédiction pour tous les
peuples de la terre
mais jacob comme son nom l'indiqué
yaacov en hébreu
signifie le tordu
tordu moralement évidemment
ça veut dire menteur
supplante heures
et à ce niveau là jacob va bel et bien
mérité son nom
il va tromper son frère les a eus et
puis ensuite il va tromper son propre
père
est le résultat de ce comportement
eh bien ça va être un jugement
il va devoir quitter la terre sainte il
va devoir quitter le pays promis et il
va connaître lui aussi une forme d'exil
message d'israël
ont fait une lecture du livre là de la
jeunesse très particulière
le livre la jeunesse pour eux n'est pas
seulement le livre des commencements
mais c'est aussi un livre prophétique
ses livres prophétiques si on en fait
une lecture à laquelle nous chrétiens
nous ne sommes pas habitués et qui part
du principe suivant
ce qui est arrivé au patriarche est une
prophétie de ce qui arrivera leurs
descendants au temps de la fin
et par conséquent si nous lisons le
livre de la genèse de cette manière nous
découvrons toute l'histoire et tout
l'avenir du peuple d'israël
le peuple d'israël
et bien une certaine manière est incarné
aussi par jacques robe
et le peuple d'israël peuple élu comme
jacob était ténue
n'est pas un pop up parfait loin de là
c'est un peuple aussi
qui mérite le nom de jacob et qui
souvent est appelée jacob dans
l'écriture chez les prophètes en
particulier
et quand il est nommé jacob
c'est pour mettre en exergue ses failles
ses manquements ces péchés ses fautes
et comme le dit la liturgie du la prière
du matin encore aujourd'hui pour tous
les juifs du mordent à cause de nos
péchés nous avons été exilé de ce pays
jacob va devoir s'exiler à cause de ces
péchés
et le peuple d'israël va être exilé à
cause de ces péchés
pour jacques or cet exil c'est une
épreuve
une épreuve difficile
jacobs et il dit n'est pas un aventurier
c'est un homme tranquille qui vit dans
les tentes
et qui est loin d'avoir le caractère
impétueux impulsif
bagarreur de son frère esaü
ce sont deux garçons qui sont totalement
contraste sur le plan du caractère
et pour lui quitté la tranquillité de
ses tantes la sécurité du camp de
beersheva
c'est une épreuve difficile il part tout
seul
il fait une journée de marche
et puis il arrive à cet endroit nous
étions il ya quelques jours à bethel
le soleil se couche c'est le moment de
bivouaquer de passer la nuit
et il prend ses dispositions pour cela
et voilà il trouve une pierre une pierre
banal une paire quelconque
la première pierre qui lui tombe sous la
main
et il va en faire son chevet
et il s'endort profondément
et c'est alors qu'il a un rêve le fameux
rêve qui était bouclée dans le chapitre
28 du livre la genèse je ne lirai pas ce
texte ce soir pour gagner un peu de
temps vous le connaissez si vous ne
connaissez mal voulu relire et dans le
chapitre 28 du livre de la genèse
là nous est dû
une voix une échelle
dont le sommet touche le ciel
et la base repose sur la pièce sur
laquelle il est couché
et le long de cette échelle les anges de
dieu montent et descendent
le mot échelle n'est pas peut-être une
traduction tout à fait approprié
dans l'hébreu il est question d'une
chaude âme
eshu l'âme ça signifie littéralement des
degrés
donc c'est plutôt un escalier
gigantesque qu'une échelle proprement
dit que jacob aperçoit dans son rêve
et
beaucoup de commentateurs de plus en
plus pense
que en réalité ces degrés c marche
c'est tiscali gigantesque ressemblent à
des structures que l'on rencontre en
babylonie
dans toute la région de la mésopotamie à
cette période là
ce sont des trous à étage que l'on
appelle la balise ziggourat
et tout un étage
ce sont des espèces de pyramide mais des
pyramides à degrés et qui sont situés en
principe entre le ciel et la terre
et la tour de babel
la tour de babel que nous avons évoquées
jus dans le chapitre 11 du livre de la
genèse et le ziggourat qui se trouve à
babylone
en mésopotamie chaque ville a son ubu
rate
et le ziggourat est en fait une
plateforme sur laquelle au sommet de
laquelle se trouve un tank
c'est à dire que le tank est situé entre
le ciel et la terre
et c'est entre le ciel et la terre que
les adorateurs vous rencontrez la
divinité
et c'est ainsi que les élus rate son la
porte du ciel
la demeure de dieu on monte et on
descend le long de ses degrés pour
chercher dieu
et voilà jacob dans son rêve aperçoit
atteint figure at
mais azille rate
qui n'est pas situé en babylonie
bel et bien situés sur la terre d'israël
et plus précisément à l'endroit même où
il est couché
et cette pierre cette pierre banale
cette pierre quelconque
cette première pierre qui lui tombait
sous la main et dont il a fait son
chevet il se rend compte que c'est le
soubassement de ces hydrates de cet
escalier gigantesque qui mène à dieu
et jacob va être saisie de crainte
que seul voeu est redoutable
ce n'est rien moins que la maison de
dieu et la porte du ciel
et là nous comprenons
le message que dieu veut communiquer à
chaque club en lui donnant cette vision
jacob part en exil
il parle d'exil en babylonie et la
babylonie
c'est d'une certaine manière
la civilisation la culture
la plus développés du monde du monde
alors
c'est qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire
cccc la californie de l'époque quelque
sorte
hélas dieu sait que jacobs est en danger
va se trouver en danger un baby données
danger d'être séduit
parce que cette civilisation à deux
brillants
d'attractif de séduisants
et
jacob
risque d'être séduits par cette idée
qui est partagée pratiquement partout
les habitants du monde antique que la
babylonie c'est vraiment la porte du
ciel c'est vraiment la maison des dieux
c'est vraiment la porte des dieux
et
parce que justement jacob risque d'être
séduits par cette vision là
dieu donne à jacob la vision de
l'échelle de bethel
et c'est un message qui est celui ci
ne trompent pas t'adresse jacob
et parce que tu vas voir des
constructions splendide
des constructions matériel
mais aussi des constructions
intellectuelles
cela dit dans babylon et
sache que
malgré les apparences
la babylonie n'est pas la maison de dieu
n'est pas la porte du ciel n'est pas la
porte des dieux
mais il ya un seul pays une seule terre
qui revendique ce privilège là et c'est
la terre sur laquelle tu es couché c'est
la terre que tu as quitté
et
ne te laisse pas tromper par les
séductions que tu vas rencontrer là-bas
le peuple d'israël
ne construira jamais
de des pyramides
ne construira jamais de ces virades
mais à part le temple qui détruit le
peuple d'israël ne construira pas des
édifices grandiose
mais le peuple d'israël construira des
pyramides de l'esprit
où sont les bâtisseurs des pyramides
aujourd'hui
où sont les bâtisseurs d yves bur hâte
dans des musées
l'égyptien modernes n'ont plus rien à
voir avec les bâtisseurs des pyramides
les irakiens modernes n'ont plus rien à
voir avec les constructeurs des élus
rate
israël n'a rien construite semblables
mais israël a construit des pyramides de
l'esprit
et là où les autres peuples ont disparu
le peuple d'israël continue lui à
exister
et
dieu donc averti jacques up
la maison de dieu c'est ici
c'est ici et pas ailleurs
voilà
le problème c'est que jacob va quitter
ce pays qui est le centre du monde
ce pays
qui est le lieu à partir duquel dieu
veut donner sa bénédiction au monde
entier
est d'accord va connaître bien des
tribulations bien des vicissitudes dans
son exil t il
c'est un jugement l'exil c'est quelque
chose de négatif
et voilà il ya des anges
des orges qui montent et qui descendent
je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec l'interprétation que notre ami
david passe des rats données de ces
anges quand il était avec nous il ya
quelques jours
par politesse je n'ai pas voulu
évidemment le contredire mais je mets un
gros point d'interrogation sur
l'interprétation qui a été la sienne
les anges ce sont des envoyés de dieu
il y a des anges qui monte il ya des
anges qui descendent il ya d'abord des
anges qui descendait les ensuite des
anges rue monte
il faudrait que ceux qui ont du mal à ma
montant de sa proche parce que moi je ne
peux pas aller lever la voix je pars je
ne peux pas forcer sur ma voix
alors si vous avez des difficultés je
vois que nous y difficulté
approchez-vous
donc il ya des anges qui descendent et
il ya des anges rindt
des centres
le peuple là le pays d'israël est le
centre du monde
et d'où que l'on vienne dans le monde
même si vous venez
de la sucent
même si vous venez du sommet de
l'himalaya
quand vous vous dirigez vers jérusalem
vous montez
bon jérusalem située dans les montagnes
mais comme disent nos amis suisses
vous appelez ça vous des montagnes nous
chez nous on appelle ça des collines est
c'est bien possible
mais dans la géographie spirituel de la
bible
jérusalem est situé au centre du monde
et sur les plus hautes les la plus
grande la plus belle la plus grande des
auteurs
par conséquent quand on se dirige
jérusalem on montre
et al'inverse canton qu'il jérusalem on
descend
jacob va quitter israël par conséquent
il descend
et voilà les anges descente
ça veut dire des anges c'est un message
que dieu comme unique à jacob oui jacob
tu descends tu quittes ce pays
tue cuts la terre promise du culte la
terre sainte
et tu vas connaître toutes sortes dessus
de séduction de tribulations de problème
mais sois sans crainte
des anges ont accompagné dans ton exil
tu ne seras pas seul
et dieu fait la promesse je te garderai
par conséquent des anges vont aller avec
toi vont descendre avec toi
ces anges ils vont te garder ils vont te
protéger
il veut te délivrer dans les difficultés
que tu connaîtras
et puis dit le seigneur
un temps viendra où je te ramènerait
dans ce pays
un temps viendra où tu remontera dans ce
pays
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il y a des anges qui monte
après qu'on a vu des anges qui
descendait on descend d'abord et on veut
monte après je te ferai remonter dans ce
pays là
parce que c'est là que j'accomplirai
toutes les promesses que j'ai faite
envers toi
et tu
sais donc qu'ici un message important
que dieu comme unique à jacob au moment
où jacob va quitter la terre promise
et quand jacob se réveille il a compris
le message que ce lieu est redoutable
ce n'est rien moins que la maison de
dieu bethel ça veut dire la maison de
dieu et la porte du ciel c'est à dire
bab line la véritable babylone
la véritable babylone ça veut dire la
maison la porte du ciel la porte du dieu
ne se trouve pas en mésopotamie mais se
trouve bel et bien dans ce pays là et
jacob a compris la leçon et il ne
l'oubliera pas
et c'était le message que je voulais lui
communiquer
j'accorde va prendre cette pierre
cette pierre sur laquelle il était
couché
et il va l'ériger en sten ça veut dire
il va la redresser
et quand on ériger une stèle
ça voulait dire que l'on sanctifie un
lieu
un lieu où quelque chose un événement à
caractère spirituel s'est terré s'est
réalisé s'étaient manifestés
et à cause de cette vision et à cause du
de la sainteté de ce lieu de cet endroit
qu'il pensait être un endroit banal il
était arrivé par hasard dans ce lieu il
s'était arrêté par hasard il avait pris
cette pierre par hasard et soudain jacob
réalise que ce n'était pas du tout par
hasard
mais que tout cela a été voulu et
conduit par dieu chaque détail de cette
aventure était conduit par dieu
ce lieu est redoutable ce n'est pas un
lieu banal ce n'est pas un dieu
quelconque
c'est la maison et la demeure même de
dieu
et cette pierre qu'il pensait être banal
cette pierre qu'il avait l'intention de
rejeter quand il s'en serait servi pour
pouvoir poursuivre sa route vers la
babylonie
il réalise que c'est une pierre ste
c'est le marche pied de ce sivu rate
c'est la base de cet escalier
gigantesque y mener jusqu'au ciel et sur
lesquels les anges de dieu monter
descendre c'est véritablement ce que été
ne figura dans la conception des
babyloniens la porte du ciel
alors cette pierre il faut l'honorer
il faut
ériger une stèle
est non seulement ils érigent ans tél
mais inédit qui l'avait induit lé
andré chouraqui
traduira cette expression de la manière
suivante il l'a messier
parce que messi machy art en hébreu ça
vient du verbe l'hymne shore qui
signifie moindre
qu'est ce que c'est que le messie c'est
le roi qui a été moins par dieu
world huile mais
l'onction d'huile et l image est le
symbole d'une autre fonction invisible
qui devait être le fait du roi c'est à
dire l'onction du saint-esprit
et cette pierre
dans la tradition rabbinique c'est très
intéressant de lire les commentaires des
rabats sur cet épisode que nous avons lu
où nous méditons ce soit très exactement
où nous est dit que cette pierre c'est
la pierre dont il est question dans le
psaume 118 où il est écrit la pierre
qu'on veut jeter ce qui bâtissait est
devenue la pléiade principal de l'angle
c'est un prodige à nos yeux mais c'est
ce que l'éternel a fait
est là claire quidet été rejetée dix les
rabbins n'était autre que le messie
et voilà
jacob avait rencontré cette pierre
cette pierre qui pour lui était une
pierre banal et qu'il avait l'intention
de rejeter
et alors qu'il avait l'intention de la
rejeter ils s'imaginent ils se
rencontrent que cette pierre n'est pas
n'importe quel pierre mais quelle est la
pierre principal la pierre de l'angle
et c'est une pierre précieuse choisi par
dieu et il va la reconnaître et
l'honorer comme tel
je vous ai dit que
les rabbins font une lecture de
l'écriture
de la jeunesse en particulier à partir
du principe selon lequel ce qui est
arrivé au patriarche est une prophétie
de ce qui arrivera leurs descendants au
temps de la fin
première
similitude l'exil du peuple d'israël
de la même manière que jacob part en
exil
le peuple d'israël va partir en exil
mais au moment même où le peuple
d'israël part en exil dieu lui fait une
promesse je serai avec toi
les anges
accompagneront toi peuple d'israël il ta
compagne ronde en tout et exil
ils garderont est le protégeons u ne
délivreront de toutes les tribulations
que tu pourras connaître et quand le
temps viendra
d'autres ange te feront remonter dans ce
pays est accompagneront
mais auparavant
ce sera produit ce drame
ou la pierre lapierre messianique le
messie
aura été rejetée
et
il faudra que le peuple d'israël où tant
de la faim
réalise que cette pierre qui l'a rejetée
et l ati pièce principale de langue
et cette pierre devrait être élevé
et les commentaires rabbinique font
allusion à un autre texte que nous
connaissons bien nous chrétiens que nous
affection particulièrement c'est le
texte d'isaïe 52 sur le serviteur de
l'éternel le serviteur souffrant et ace
52 et 53 la fin du chapitre 52 et le
chapitre 53
la fin du chapitre 52 nous dit ceci
voici mon serviteur s'élèvera
il s'élèvera il s'élèvera bien aux
trois fois dans ce texte il est dit que
le serviteur s'élèvera
le fait que trois fois il soit mentionné
le
la réalité que le serviteur sera élevé
nous empêche pas de dormir nous les
chrétiens en général
les juifs lui
et on se pose la question
pourquoi le saint-esprit at il
éprouvé le besoin de nouveaux venus de
rappeler à trois reprises que le messie
s'élèvera
à relier un texte que nous avons
retrouvé à qumrân mais qu'on connaissait
déjà par un écrit du moyen âge je
n'écris rabbinique du moyen-âge ce qui
prouve que cet écrit était très ancien
il était connu à l'époque du du deuxième
temple c'est à dire à l'époque du
nouveau testament était connue de jésus
il était connu des apôtres
et ce texte dit ceci trois fois et nous
est dit que le serviteur s'élèvera et ce
serviteur c'est la pierre du bétel
cette pierre qui devait être rejetée
mais qui deviendra la pierre principal
la pierre de langue et qui par
conséquent de la même manière que jacob
adressé cette pierre l'a élevé pour en
faire une stèle
de la même manière cette pierre sera
élevé
et en suisse ce round ou un truc du
saint-esprit comme jacob a moins la
pierre de bethel avec de l'huile
pourquoi trois fois l'étude question de
cette élévation du messie
pourquoi trois fois est il question de
l'innovation de cette pierre
parce que le messie le serviteur de
l'éternel s'élèvera au dessus de tout ce
qui serait leur a produit de mieux
qu est ce qui serait là produit de mieux
et bien la première c'est ce que nous
avons parlé c'est abraham
abraham
c'est le point de départ c'est le rocher
il est comparé à un rocher dans le
chapitre 51 le livre du prophète isaïe
porter les regards vers abraham votre
père le rocher dont vous avez été tiré
le rocher la pierre on retrouve cette
idée aussi dans ces chapitres 51 du
livre du prophète isaïe
voici mon serviteur s'élèvera
donc dit le commentaire
le serviteur
s'élèvera plus haut qu abraham il sera
plus élevé qu abraham
et puis une deuxième fois il est dit que
le serviteur s'élèvera
donc il s'élèvera au dessus d'un
deuxième personnage qui est aussi ce qui
serait là produit de mieux
après abraham qu'est ce qui serait là
produit de mieux
la réponse est simple moïse
par conséquent le messie s'élèvera au
dessus de maurice
et puis troisième mention de l'élévation
du messie
il s'élèvera il s'élèvera et il
s'élèvera bientôt
on a parlé d'abraham on a parlé de moïse
peut-on trouver dans l'histoire d'israël
quelque chose qui soit plus élevé que
ces deux personnages là non
donc il faut chercher le troisième
s'élèvera non plus sur la terre mais
dans le ciel
et dans le ciel qu'est ce qu'il y à des
levées
jérusalem
jérusalem et les sur terre une jérusalem
céleste c'est vrai aussi mais ce sont
des personnages c'est pas c'est pas une
réalité une matériel disons matériel
plus exactement non ce sont les anges
[Musique]
et le texte dit ceci le serviteur
s'élèvera plus haut que les anges du
service il y a eu toute une hiérarchie
angélique
il ya des anges qui sont plus élevés en
dignité que d'autres et au sommet de la
hiérarchie en génie qu il y a ceux qu'on
appelle les anges du service
est nommé ci s'élèvera plus haut que les
anges du service le serviteur s'élèvera
donc plus haut qu abraham plus haut que
moïse est plus haut que les anges du
service trois fois il s'élèvera
or
si vous lisez l'épître aux hébreux
vous allez constater que c'est
exactement le plan de l'épître aux
hébreux
l'auteur de l'épître commence par
démontrer qu abraham est supérieur aux
ans que je que jésus est supérieur aux
anges
auquel des ans jacqueline a été dit il
cite le pauvre tu es mon fils je t'ai
engendré aujourd'hui
deuxièmement
l'épître aux hébreux nous montre que
jésus est supérieur à moïse qui a été
fidèle dans toute la maison de dieu
et troisièmement les plus aux hébreux
nous montre que jésus est supérieur à
bram ce qui veut dire que l'auteur de
l'épître aux hébreux connaissait ce
midrash là ils connaissaient ce
commentaire et il cite
et ça c'est directement en relation avec
le songe de bethel
et il ya l'idée
que cette pierre de bethel
elle a été ça c'est le midrash une
démence et à ses légendaires je le cite
quand même parce que c'est quand même
intéressant de le savoir
le l'appelèrent de bethel cette pierre
qui était la pierre messianique par
expérience
et bien elle a été transportée à
jérusalem
est
sous le dôme du rocher
ça veut dire sur
ce sur le lait d'ornano hibou siens
endroit où se dressera le temple de
jérusalem par la suite est bien le
temple s'élèvera sur cette claire là ça
veut dire sur le messie qui est aussi à
sa manière un temple le temple du
seigneur
jésus disait
à ses adversaires détruisez ce top et en
trois jours je leur bâtir est et il
parle et nous étions du temple de son
corps
par conséquent ici de mais si on attend
on retrouve un écho de ce midrash là
aussi dans ce texte que je viens
d'évoquer
donc ici le songe de bethel
c'est aussi l'idée
que
jacques up et bien comme ses descendants
devra élever cette stèle
pour pouvoir entrer dans les promesses
du tueur
et là commence alors pouvait nous
arrêter longtemps sur le longue exil de
jakob chez la banque
et là il va connaître effectivement bien
des vicissitudes
jacob est un malin rusé
c'est un tordu nous avons vu tout à
l'heure yaacov
mais comme le dit le proverbe du monde à
malin malin et demi
il va trouver plus malin que lui son
beau père
et il va se fait rouler par son beau
père lui qui avait l'habitude de rouler
les autres c'est lui qui va être voulait
il avait profité de l'obscurité dans
laquelle son père était plongé dans la
cécité pour se tromper pour le tromper
plus exactement
est bien là bord va profiter de
l'obscurité de la nuit pour le tromper
au sujet de son épouse
l'épousé voilée donc
quand l'épousé a été présenté il a cru
que c'était rachel
et c'est au petit matin quand la lumière
du jour s'est levé qui s'est rendu
compte que c'étaient les a il avait été
trompée et
la banque va exiger de lui un nouveau
service de sept ans
afin avant de lui donner rachel et
ensuite ça toute cette histoire des
troupeaux ou les uns les autres l'un et
l'autre rivalisent de ruses de tromperie
et finalement jacob ne essentielle ne
s'en sortent pas trop mal parce que
comme il le dit lui-même et bien d'une
certaine manière même dans
ce genre de manifestation là dieu est
avec lui
mais est un moment où je règle les
comptes
dieu est patient mais ce n'est pas
éternel
jacob est installé chez la banque il est
très bien
il a quelque sorte oublier le pays
d'israël une absolument pas l'intention
d'y revenir
et voilà il va y avoir un contentieux
qui va éclater entre lui et son beau
père qui va l'obliger contre son gré un
revenu dans le pays d'israël
et les sages d'israël dit ceci les
commentateurs dès le moyen âge en
espagne et dit ceci
autant de la fin
dieu nous obligera à revenir dans le
pays d'israël
et il ne faudrait pas prier comme on le
fait
nous avons été exilé de ce pays à cause
de nos péchés
mais
c'est à cause du péché que nous avons
commis en nous exigeons de ce pays là
c'est nous qui nous sommes exilés en fin
de compte
est le véritable péché du peuple
d'israël c'est d'habiter loin du pays
promet
et il ne faut pas croire que les juifs
qui sont venus dans ce pays ne sont
revenus par idéal un petit nombre l'a
fait oui mais si on n'a pas la majorité
et s'il ya aujourd'hui près de la moitié
du peuple juif rassemblés dans ce pays
c'est essentiellement parce qu'ils ont
été forcés et contraints par la colère
des nations exactement comme jacob a été
obligé de revenir dans le pays promis
contre son gré
et jacob se remet en route pour arriver
en israël
hélas
il y à
une situation de non-retour un point de
non retour est atteint
la banque poursuit paul y faire un
mauvais un mauvais sort
et dieu va intervenir pour
empêcher la mort de m c ces projets à
exécution ce qui concerne jacob mais il
va y avoir un accord conclu entre le
beau père est le gendre où ils vont
établir un
un monceau un morceau de pierre qui va
être un signe une frontière
l'abord n'ira pas vers le vers l'ouest
pour aller vers jacob mais j'accorde ne
retournera pas vers l'est pour aller
vers l'avant ça veut dire que tout
retour en arrière est impossible il se
met en route vers l'ouest vers le pays
d'israël mais il n'a plus du tout quoi
qu'il arrive la possibilité de revenir
en arrière c'est vraiment le point de
non retour a été atteint
et la jacob arrive en vue du pays de
canaan en vue du jourdain
bien il a une petite crainte avant de
franchir le joueur
quelles sont les dispositions de son
frère esaü
il a quitté le pays d'israël à cause de
la colère déjà eu à cause de la haine
déjà eu et à cause des volonté homicide
déjà eu des projets homicide et a eu
le temps a passé des années ont passé
plus de 14 ans passé
que jacob se dit oh la colère des a eu
un dut s'apaiser
donc le temps fait a fait son oeuvre et
puis
on va pouvoir s'arranger
mais il tient en être sûr
et il envoie des messagers versons vers
son frère
pour lui signaler son retour
et les messages y reviennent dans dix
ans à jacob tôt faire et je viens à ta
rencontre avec 400 hommes pour régler
ton compte
ça veut dire
que la colère déjà eu n'a pas diminué
d'un gramme
il est toujours dans les mêmes
dispositions d'esprit
que celles dans lesquelles il était
quand jacob a quitté le pays de canaan
et jacob patrick
voyez-vous
là aussi c'est une prophétie de ce qui
arrivera aux temps de la fin
il s'agit serait nous dit ceci
quand nous reviendrons dans le pays
promet la colère des nations n'aura pas
diminué
après la shoah on aurait pu penser que
le bon vieil antisémitisme
aurait disparu que les nations se
rendrait compte de l'énormité de leur
crime et par conséquent sans
détournerait s'en repentir et et nous
voyons aujourd'hui que soixante dix ans
après la shoah eh bien on est revenu au
point zéro on est revenu exactement la
situation entre les deux guerres
mondiales en ce qui concerne
l'antisémitisme européen
antisémitisme même la haine déjà eu n'a
pas diminué d'un pouce et les sages ont
vu on les a eu une image de l'europe et
du christianisme au temps de la fin
il y a deux frères ennemis deux frères
jumeaux que sont les a eus et jacob et
que sont le christianisme judaïsme
christianisme et judaïsme pour le
polissage du stress son frère frère
ennemi et on sait qu'il n'ya pas de
pyrène de pire inimitiés que celle de
frère
et par conséquent ici
c'est à cause de la haine de ce frère
aîné qui serait là du célé s'exiler et
ce sont en effet les romains y compris
le lampy romain devenu chrétien entre
guillemets qui ont contraint le peuple
d'israël à s'exiler
et l'on voudrait plus penser qu'au temps
de la fin 2000 ans après alors qu'israël
revient dans son pays
cette haine s est estompée eh bien non
elle est intacte
et jacob qui est un malin va tenter un
certain nombre de manoeuvre pour essayer
d'amadouer son frère
et notamment il va lui faire des petits
cadeaux
et il envoie des troupeaux séparés les
uns des autres par une certaine distance
avec un message et à la rencontre des a
eu
et il y au premier quand tu rencontreras
mon frère tu diras à ce dernier d'en
accepter un petit cadeau de la part de
ton frère jacob qui désirent par ce
moyen là trouvé grâce à tes yeux
et avant que j'accuse a eu le tort de
revenir de sa surprise
un deuxième troupeau arrivera
avec un messager qui dira la même chose
et ce serait bien extraordinaire
si en fin de compte pense jacob et esaü
ne se laissait pas séduire ne cessait
pas fléchi
mais il n'est pas très sûre néanmoins
et les sages israël ont dit ceci autant
de la fin quand nous reviendrons dans le
pays promis contraint et forcé
et bien il y aura une tentation d'
essayer d'amadouer nous adversaire en
faisant des concessions en faisant des
cadeaux
souvenez vous par exemple de gaza des
accords d'oslo
et de tous ces choses
mais cela ne servira à rien
cela ne servira que nous donner entre
deux concessions nous aurons fait nous
aurons un petit temps de paix
mais la colère de nos frères ne sera que
plus grande après et cela ne servira à
rien du tout
jacob va devoir
se trouver dans une situation où il est
coincé entre deux feux
d'un côté du côté de l'est son beau-père
la banque qui
le
ne peut plus le recevoir et d'un côté
son frère esaü qui marche ça on
compterait 400 hommes
jacquot panique comme il est très
courageux les femmes et les enfants
d'abord
il fait passer ces femmes et ces enfants
devant et lui reste courageusement
derrière
le moment où ils arrivent au vu du
jourdain t ange leurent contraire nous
étiquetés
et jacob appellent ce lieu mara naim ça
veut dire les deux camps parce qu'ils
rencontrent deux troupes d'ange
des anges qui l'accompagnent et des
hommes qui viennent à sa rencontre
autrement dit des anges qui descendent
et des anges ils mentent et il reconnaît
dans ses anges des anges de bethel
c'est nouveau un message de dieu
alors que jacob panique dieu lui dit
n'aie pas peur jacob les anges qui t'ont
accompagner et qui te ramène maintenant
dans ce pays et bien
vont encore te protéger de la colère de
ton frère
et tu vas revenir dans son dans ce pays
et les 11 qui descendent à tharon
comptes sont là pour t'accueillir et
pour te fais rentrer dans ce pays mais
auparavant il ya la lutte avec l'ange
[Musique]
alors ça et où il serait dès 12 heures
pour pouvoir
étudier toutes les profondeurs de ce
texte
mais
évidemment
c'est avec dieu lui-même qui luttent
ce n'est pas un ange ordinaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle en hébreu l'ange
de la phase
c'est-à-dire une hypostase divine une
manifestation de dieu
et
pendant toute la nuit le combat a lieu
dans l'obscurité
donc jacob ne distingue pas son
adversaire il ne sait pas à qui il a à
faire
mais quand lieu ce matin le soleil se
lève il se rend compte qu'il est en
train de se battre contre un ange et pas
n'importe quel ange je longe de
l'éternel lui-même loges de la face
c'est à dire contre dieu lui-même et il
voit dieu face à face dans cette
confrontation
or il sait parfaitement bien que
personne ne peut voir la face de dieu
est vive
et la jacobs se rend compte qu'il est en
danger de mort il a vu dieu face à face
une logiquement il doit mourir de cette
rencontre là
et c'est pourquoi quand l'ange lui dit
laisse moi aller parce que maintenant le
jour s'est levé jacob le retient en
disant non je ne te laisserai pas allé
sans que tu nous mets béni parce qu'il
est placé sous une malédiction et cette
malédiction c'est la malédiction de son
péché
et 10 change la malédiction bénédiction
et finalement dieu va se laisser fléchir
et il va changer la malédiction en
bénédiction
et jacob va recevoir un nouveau
yaakov le tordu le menteur le supplante
heures
pas laisser de la place à israël
israël c'est la bri l'abréviation d'un
autre nom qui lui est parfois donné dans
un certain nombre d'autres textes qui
échoue vu israel yashar elle
sait exactement le contraire de yaacov
yaacov c'est le tordu
yashar c'est celui qui est droit les
chun d'achat est ni israël ni achat n
c'est le juste de dieu
jacob et redresser
il cesse d'être le tordu pour devenir un
homme juste un homme droit aux yeux du
tueur
israël est une autre et une étymologie
possible également
c'est sarita et est elohim
dans la chimie et elohim tu as combattu
contre dieu
contre des hommes et tu as été vainqueur
israël c'est celui qui luttent contre
dieu au nom des hommes et qui luttent
contre les hommes au nom de dieu
et
jacob on va donc ici
se mettre en ordre avec dieu
pendant ce combat de péniel dieu règle
ses comptes avec jacob dieu l'empêchent
de franchir le jourdain parce qu'il ne
peut pas franchir le jourdain en tant
que jacob entend que le vieux jacobs
loewe tordu dessus planteurs il faut
qu'ils soient changés il faut qu'ils
soient transformés et ce n'est que
lorsqu'il est transformé qu'il est
devenu israël qui traversent ou le
jourdain
et c'est en tant qu israël qu'il va
rencontrer esaü son frère
et voyez-vous ce qui est extraordinaire
que l'on noté les sages israël c'est
qu'à partir du moment où
jacob a réglé ses comptes avec dieu et
où tout est en ordre avec dieu
et bien la colère de son père disparaît
comme par enchantement
et ce qui aurait dû se terminer par un
bain de sang dans cette rencontre outre
jacob et esaü se termine par la
réconciliation entre les deux frères ça
veut dire des messages d'israël que la
colère de jacob c'était la colère des
russes étaient en réalité la colère de
dieu
et qu'à partir du moment où jacob est en
règle avec dieu la colère des élus n'a
plus lieu d'être et elle disparaît comme
par enchantement
et voyez-vous extraordinaire c'est que
le commentaire des sages du moyen âge
dit ceci
quand nous reviendrons dans notre pays
il y aura de la part de des habitants du
pays et du christianisme il y aura de la
colère contre nous
il y aura une volonté de nous empêcher
de revenir dans ce pays ils feront tout
pour nous empêcher de revenir dans le
pays
est en réalité
c'est parce que du sera hérité contre
nous parce que nous serons en
porte-à-faux vis-à-vis de dieu
mais quand dieu vous re a réglé ses
comptes avec nous quand nous nous serons
réconcilier avec dieu nous
réconcilierons avec nos frères nous nous
réconcilierons avec eichmann les arabes
et nous nous réconcilions nous
réconcilierons avec les a eus le
christianisme
et voyez vous ce qui devait ce qu'est
une
arrivée au père au patriarche est une
prophétie jusque là rivera à leurs
descendants au temps de la fin et nous
sommes en train de vivre exactement ces
professionnels
et nous avons créé l'ange de la face
l'ange la face c'est jésus
et il faudra que le peuple d'israël se
tourner vers jésus pour que je puisse
trouver la paix dans ce pays et qu'il
puisse y avoir réconciliation avec les
arabes et avec les chrétiens
il faudra aussi une conversion des
chrétiens
un retour des chrétiens au seigneur
et c'est pourquoi ce que nous faisons
ici c'est aussi
ce premier pas de cette réconciliation
nous sommes en quelque sorte nous qui
sommes les chrétiens amis d'israël nous
sommes les pionniers
de cette réconciliation qui se
manifestera autant de la fin de cette
reconnaissance que le peuple d'israël
malgré ces failles malgré ses fautes
reste et demeure le pape du dieu et que
ce qui est en train de se produire et
l'accomplissement des professions et
l'accomplissement des desseins de dieu
je te ramènerait je ne te notamment
donnerez pas jusqu'à ce que je te ramène
dans ce pays aussi ne craint pas jacob
mon serviteur
et
dieu ramène ce peuple dans ce pays
pour accomplir les promesses qui avaient
été faites à bram
je rendrai ton nom grand
et parce que je rendrais ton nom grand
parce que tu accepteras de te laisser
nommer par mois ce qu'israël n'a pas
toujours fait ce qu'israël a été séduit
aussi comme jacob risques et de lettres
paris babylone des nations et combien
aujourd'hui encore ans dans ce pays dix
de juifs d'israéliens sont séduits par
les babylon des nations
et il faudra que le vieux jacob sera
détruit pour que
et bien israël accepte de se laisser
nommer par dieu et que deux rondes sont
en gras
et qu'ils reviennent ici cet endroit que
la porte du ciel la maison de dieu qui
est cet endroit où doit être dressé
cette stèle cette pierre qui a été
rejetée mais qui devient la principale
de l'angle et sur laquelle se dresse cet
édifice ce temps où toutes les nations
afflueront autant de la faim pour que
s'accomplisse la promesse qu'elle avait
faite à abraham je bénirai ce qui te
béniront et toutes les nations de la
terre seront bénis en toi
ce sont des choses que nous sommes en
train de vivre aujourd'hui ce sont ces
accomplissements de ces antiques
prophétie nous voyons s'accomplir sous
nos yeux et par conséquent nous pouvons
aussi entrer dans cette perspective est
dans cette dimension sans attendre les
ultimes rebondissements de cette
aventure là mais sachant qu'elle que le
dénouement de ce drame est proche et que
par conséquent nous aussi nous sommes
appelés à être ces instruments de la
réconciliation finale telle que le
seigneur l'a voulu voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire ce soir